this episode is brought to you by
curiosity stream curiosity stream is a
subscription streaming service that
offers over 2000 documentaries and
nonfiction titles from some of the
world's best filmmakers including
exclusive originals if you're enjoying
our videos here a visual politic why not
once you've done here of course hop on
over to curiosity stream try it out for
free and explore some of their political
content they've got dozens of
documentary titles all about politics so
you're sure to find something you'll
enjoy it's also available on many
platforms Roku Android Xbox one smart TV
iOS chromecast Amazon fire Amazon Kindle
Apple TV and it's also available
worldwide so wherever you are you'll be
able to get it unlimited access starts
at just $2.99 a month and for you guys
the first 30 days are completely free if
you sign up a curiosity stream com
forward slash visual politic and use the
promo code visual politic one word
during the signup process that's a great
way to support this show keeps making
more videos check it out through the
link below and let's get into it
[Applause]
[Music]
despite being a small country with
barely 20 million inhabitants for at
least the last seven decades taiwan has
been a hotspot of international politics
its official name is not Taiwan but the
Republic of China this is because its
origin goes back to the country that
emerged in China after the sing high
Revolution of 1912 a revolution that led
to the fall of the Qing Dynasty however
the story doesn't end there
a few years later China was to face a
new nightmare with the invasion of the
Japanese Empire which managed to control
the richest and most powerful parts of
the new country and whose capitulation
in 1945 served as a breeding ground for
the outbreak of a new power struggle
that of Mao's communists against the
Republicans of the coaming tang
nationalists
and so you could probably guess who won
right now was able to establish his
People's Republic in mainland China
while the leaders of the
counter-revolution and what remained of
their army settled on the island of
Formosa there they created a state
considered for decades to be the
legitimate successor of the model
governments that existed in mainland
China prior to the invasion of Japan and
the subsequent communist revolution and
in this way for more than 30 years the
Nationalist government of Taiwan whilst
many countries he valid interlocutor the
governments of China the natural
successor of the Singh hi revolution the
legitimate government of the entire
country
viewed from this perspective Mao's
regime was nothing more than a
governments that illegitimately occupied
mainland China in fact that has
traditionally mean the claim of the
Taiwanese authorities and we need to
tread carefully because we are not
exactly talking about a democracy us of
a rigid dictatorship under the control
of Chiang kai-shek to give you an idea
there were no elections held there until
1996 in spite of this and thanks to its
alliance with the United States until
1971 the Republic of China ie
Taiwan occupied the seat that belongs to
China at the United Nations to the
detriment of the People's Republic
founded and controlled by Mao Zedong in
1971 however everything began to change
that year Taiwan lost its seat at the UN
in favor of the People's Republic of
China
of course a country can only have one
representative at the UN if there are
two governments that consider themselves
to be legitimate then you have to choose
one or the other and therein lies the
problem
Taiwan has never been considered as an
independent country but has the
legitimate China
what a mess from that moment on
international recognition and the global
influence of Taiwan has done nothing but
plummet so what happened to the Taiwan
that was once fully recognized by all
the major Western powers while we come
of it now that mainland China has become
a superpower what happens to Taiwan's
claims and what is even more important
what can we expect after the enormous
protests that have occurred in Hong Kong
and the recent presidential elections in
January of 2020 in Taiwan
[Music]
from legitimate heir to political
nuisance other gist explains for many
years the governments of Taiwan was for
most countries the sovereign
representative of the Chinese nation of
course the increasing influence of the
People's Republic of China together with
the economic awakening of the Asian
giant has really turned the tables
Taiwan began losing recognition from all
the countries with a few exceptions from
smaller nations the United States
Taiwan's most important ally officially
switched its recognition to the People's
Republic of China to the detriment of
the Republic of China under the Carter
Administration in 1979 the United States
recognizes the government of the
People's Republic of China as a sole
legal government of China within this
context the people of the United States
will maintain cultural commercial and
other unofficial relations with the
people of Taiwan
[Music]
currently only 14 countries in addition
to the Vatican recognize the Republic of
China as the valid state of China this
situation ends the fact that even the
fiercest allies of Taiwan cease to
officially recognize them led to the
islands government abandoning its claim
as the legitimate government of China in
the early 1990s since then Taiwan has
relaxed its efforts on recognition and
has opted for a strategy that is
becoming increasingly clear and is
gaining more support over time not to be
recognized as the Republic of China but
only as Taiwan given the story so far
that makes perfect sense
the Taiwanese understand all too well
that the political social economic and
democratic measures they have taken over
the years on the islands have created a
great divide between it and mainland
China
the livestock current politics in
society in Taiwan are completely
different to what exists in the People's
Republic of China under the Communist
Party's dictatorship there are
increasing differences in Taiwanese
society and the islands government
already understands how insurmountable
these are and doesn't view the
possibility of melding with mainland
China worth the struggle purely and
simply Taiwan is a foreign country
China's suppression of Taiwan in the
international arena cannot change the
indisputable fact of time wants
existence nor can it coerce the
Taiwanese people into abandoning their
democratic and free way of life Taiwan's
Ministry of Foreign Affairs we could say
that those who only a couple of
generations ago founded a country of
exiled people on an islands have managed
to create an independent nation with its
own idiosyncrasies
and that is precisely the idea defended
by the current president sighing when of
the Democratic Progressive Party but
always a moment there is one more
important thing to point out this
particular vision is not shared by all
the common tang another major party in
Taiwan defends a very different position
to build closer ties and come to an
understanding with the Chinese regime
but hold on a moment does that name
Kuomintang ring any bells to you yes
exactly the Komen tang is the party
founded by the nationalist Republican
leaders who fought against the Chinese
Communist revolution and established
present-day Taiwan yes that's right even
though it sounds incredible the party
that once went head-to-head with the
Chinese regime now advocates to be their
friends and there are those people who
say nothing ever changes in politics so
much for that
now the question that crops up is what
on earth has led to such a turnaround
well money plays a crucial part in every
aspect of this story and I'm not just
referring to bribes kickbacks or opaque
agreements of all kinds but to the
possibility of taking advantage of the
huge economy that has been developed in
mainland China
and it is precisely here where we hit a
crucial question which would you choose
fight for the full independence of your
country although it means risking
economic relations with an Asian
superpower or seek an understanding with
Beijing this is not an easy question by
any means this is the big question the
Taiwanese are trying to answer and their
collective answer will determine the
electoral results
now before we go on there is a question
we haven't covered what's been happening
with Taiwan since it began losing
international recognition has it been
isolated the short answer is no Taiwan
is an exception it is not officially
considered a country but there is de
facto international recognition
regarding its sovereignty and
self-government the former international
embassies have become economic and
cultural officers which act as embassies
de facto as well the Taiwanese have
identity documents and passports issued
by their own governments that are
internationally recognized
[Music]
and this is something that angers
Beijing few things bother the
governments of the People's Republic of
China as much as seeing how Taiwan is in
practice an independent country Taiwan
must and will be reunited with China
independence will only bring hardship
and the reunification with the mainland
was an inevitable requirement for the
great rejuvenation of the Chinese people
caesium ping but do not think for a
second that they put up with us Oh No
the Chinese government's the governments
of Xi Jingping
has been harassing the islands for years
with strategies designed to wear them
down how exactly well many of them I'm
sure you can imagine
[Music]
China's pockets are extremely deep and
don't make the mistake of thinking there
are only a couple of countries willing
to cast Taiwan aside in exchange for a
handful of investments we all know that
money talks but hold on a moment because
all of this does not mean that Taiwan is
alone in the world that's something that
China hasn't managed to achieve and
other things that by the way drives them
crazy as well you see even if it is only
recognized diplomatically by a handful
of governments a Taiwanese retain many
allies and common interests with a lot
of countries
in particular there's an agreement with
the u.s. that has been in place since
the end of the 70s which states that the
great American power ensures that the
islands will be stocked with military
equipment changes in the diplomatic
Korea are indeed challenging but Taiwan
still has many friends around the world
willing to stand with us and we are not
alone signing when president of Taiwan
so as we've already discussed in a
previous video that I'll leave a link
for in the description the Taiwanese
government has opted for the strategy of
differentiation we have nothing to do
with China we are Taiwan and we do not
intend to rule over anyone other than
ourselves nor allow anyone to rule over
us this is the message from presidents I
that has struck a deeper chord with
Taiwanese voters in the recent
presidential elections the victory of
psy has been overwhelming she got 58
percent of the votes a difference of
almost 20 points over the combing Tang
Party of Hanko you so this is much more
than a simple victory
what psy has done electorally is take a
steamroller to the other candidates
[Music]
but why is it that the Taiwanese have
voted in this way despite the constant
warnings of Beijing against the new
government of sighing when
[Music]
taijuan thermometer of Chinese
expansionism the recent elections of
January 2020 in Taiwan have been a
tremendous Democratic slap in the face
to the Beijing regime with the lessons
learned from the recent events in Hong
Kong that Iowan EES have seen the eyes
of the Beast clearer than ever
the constant meddling in Beijing by
hongcun ease Affairs the violation of
the special status of the city hence the
huge protests to claim back freedom have
led the Taiwanese to lose the very
little trust that they had left in China
that is why they're voted against common
tang and its trust in Beijing
trust which they claimed would result in
economic stability that is to say
Chinese money and peace in the region
put another way a reduction in the
influence of the United States
however the opinion of the Taiwanese
people has been very different nearly 20
point difference achieved by sighing
when marks the greatest electoral
victory since elections have been held
in the country results of this election
carry an added significance they've
shown that when our sovereignty is
threatened the Taiwanese people will
shout our determination even more loudly
back sighing when president of Taiwan
Tsai has been able to take advantage of
the fear the Taiwanese have about the
loss of freedom due to the influence of
China and it's a point she drove home in
a final campaign speech listen the young
people of Hong Kong have used their
lives as well as their blood and tears
to demonstrate to us that one country
two systems'
is unworkable tomorrow let our young
people of Taiwan demonstrate to them
that the values of democracy and freedom
will overcome all difficulties signing
when president of Taiwan the
difficulties that I is talking about our
international political isolation and
loss of investments the Asian Giants is
hell-bent on isolating Taipei in order
to stifle its economy and force the
island nation to surrender to their
demands if they want to maintain their
standard of living and to this end they
are not hesitating to flash some cash
[Music]
we have seen it most recently with two
of the few countries that still
recognize Taiwan as the legitimate
government of China the Solomon Islands
in Kiribati China extends influence in
Pacific as Solomon Islands break with
Taiwan
The Guardian Taiwan loses another ally
as Kiribati cuts times bbc2 small
territories in the Pacific that could
have been key for the United States in
the containment of Chinese expansionist
aspirations but now the balance seems
tilted more than ever towards Beijing
the 14 countries that still recognize
Taiwan there are only four in the South
Pacific area and the recognition or not
of Taiwan by these countries implicitly
represents their level of loyalty to the
United States against China which leaves
us very striking results
the lacs approach of the united states
in this part of the world couples with
the giant deterring power of chinese
money have ensured that no wars nor
military ships were needed to ensure
control of these seas which are very
important for well trade let's not stray
from the issue the thing is that now
with another four years of the
independent açaí ruling taiwan it is
expected that relations with Beijing
will become colder than an ice cream in
the middle of the North Pole and when we
talk about diplomatic relations and
China we're often talking about economic
blockades the challenge the president's
eye is facing because if there is one
thing Beijing has argued for both
actively and passively it's that they
will never tolerate the full
independence of Taiwan we reject the one
country two systems' model we value the
lifestyle of democracy and we defend our
sovereignty Sangwan but now it's your
turn if you were Taiwanese which would
you choose
your political and social freedoms or
China and the business do you think that
Taiwan can continue growing and
developing leaving the Chinese
superpower aside well leave your answer
in the comments below and I really hope
you enjoyed this video please do hit
that like button if you did and don't
forget to subscribe for brand new videos
please do also check our friends at the
reconsider Media podcast they provided
the vocals in this episode but we're not
mine also this channel is possible
because of patreon and our patrons on
that platform please do consider joining
them and supporting our mission of
providing independent political coverage
and as always I'll see you in the next
video if you want to learn more about
politics and world affairs and here's
some more of my lovely voice
come check out the reconsidered podcast
where we don't do the thinking for you
find reconsider @ww re consider mediacom
or on Apple or Google Play or your
favorite podcast
[Music]
[Applause]